[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
the manga king
[Music]
oh
i think they'll love it the trump
bumpers are gonna love the new nickname
that joe biden gave the former guy the
cheeto dust mobster grandpa poopy pants
the orange mussolini jesus
they're gonna love it they're gonna
absolutely love it manga king and
they're not gonna realize
they're not gonna get it
they're not gonna get it right there's
no way there's no way they understand
that joe biden is completely making fun
of them
the people who who have a orange idol at
the
at the c pack you know they rolled in
that big huge gold statue
orange statue but a gold
statue of donald trump the weird one he
had like i don't know shorts on
or some [ __ ] you remember this maybe
i'll find a picture of it eventually
that
that's the manga king manga king and
they're like yeah we like this name oh
yeah manga king we like we like when joe
biden
calls
donald trump our king our dictator we
bow down to the they don't even get it
they really they they don't even get it
we really we really are folks
we are at the intersection
of wrestlemania and real life
like that is where we are at
we have the republican party who is
yelling and screaming inflation price
hikes
the american people are going to suffer
underneath the biden regime of prices
going up so we want to tax we want to
tax the working class
that's their plan
it's their plan rick scott mitch
mcconnell got together they're like you
know what you know what's a good idea to
combat this whole high prices thing
let's tax the working people
let's do that
they'll really appreciate that the
working people they're so dumb they
won't even know
they won't even know we're taxing the
[ __ ] out of them
all the while yelling and screaming yay
elon's gonna buy twitter which he's not
because billionaires need need free
speech as if billionaires need any more
[ __ ] speech in this country like they
can't afford any more [ __ ] speech get
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
all the while they want to tax
the american working class
while they reinstall their maga king
and they're excited they're excited
about the manga king
oh man they just can't wait
they just can't wait to be under
an authoritarian rule of a manga king
they're excited on twitter today have
you seen this have you went to the manga
king thread we are gonna go
to the manga king thread
today at some point
dude do remind me hold me to it folks
don't let me [ __ ] up and forget to go to
the manga king thread you got to see
these people
oh my god
it's gross good morning everybody good
morning good morning
a ferret minus margie midas robin
debbie from salt lake
cynthia's here patty is here
the midas mighty is here folks margie
from facebook is here kathy's here cindy
from facebook matt from facebook
rhonda's here
mj good morning mj nancy's here cindy is
here lacey debra jay
oh my gosh i mean patricia's here from
facebook you guys know we broadcast
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific and holy moly
holy moly have we got some new listeners
out there you guys know we broadcast
from youtube twitter twitch
you can find us on the tubes of you you
just search the tony michaels podcast
subscribe to the channel do not
forget
to subscribe
to the tony michaels podcast channel
that is super important because you will
you will not want to miss any of the
clips the parody and the satire that are
coming down the pike
as you know gabe sanchez our executive
producer and co-host extraordinaire
that produces
uh satire and parody videos and we try
to put those together for you we will be
releasing exclusive ones over on the
youtube channel so don't forget to
subscribe
because we also simulcast this live
stream from the midas touch facebook
page so all you people over there on the
books of face all of our new listeners
over there welcome welcome welcome
but there is a link right there on the
post that leads you right to our youtube
page so you get all of the funny videos
that gabe produces here
that we work uh really hard to make you
guys laugh
at the manga king
and his and his sheep
oh my god don't forget to download the
podcast either on apple spotify and
google we are over there
you know the the craziest part is we're
live five days a week monday through
friday for two hours
and then on saturday we do a bet of and
we post it on youtube and we also post
it on the podcast directories for you to
download
and on sundays we take out bonehead of
the week and we post it on the
directories on sundays just the bonehead
of the week which we do on friday which
is tomorrow friday the 13th baby
tomorrow's a special episode because it
is friday the 13th who knows what could
happen on bonehead of the week friday
the 13th edition i don't know maybe
we'll make that nothing
but don't forget to watch tomorrow the
second hour of the show bone hint of the
week but we have a special treat for you
today if you noticed on our twitter page
and our instagrammies
and my facebook page remember you over
over on facebook call you on facebook
you can follow me on facebook just just
type in the tony michaels or d tony
michaels podcast you'll find my page
and i i printed i printed jesus what is
this the 1980s i posted an announcement
we have a special guest with us today a
special interview we play trivia folks
first time you played trivia in a while
with a guest normally we we have a long
interview for all you new listeners out
there if we have a long interview we
play we play trivia with the guest
sometimes we have poppins where they're
shorter interviews and we don't play
trivia on those we talk serious issues
like michael popock
karen ignifullo kfa both from legal af
we have rachel bittikoffer the political
strategist and on and on it goes we have
several guests
but this today we have a special guest
brett terhune
the comedian
and the uh trump troll extraordinaire i
think he's a great drum troll we have an
interview with brett that we're going to
air today you guys get to watch the
entirety of the interview
um i'm not sure exactly how long it is
it's it's uh
we we have a lot of laughs
we talk about the differences between
white trash
rednecks and hillbillies um we ex
brent explains the difference between
those so
stick around you're not going to want to
miss this interview you definitely are
not going to want to miss this interview
today
it's going to be a good one it's going
to be a good one uh i'll look look here
um
we have a we have a super chat i gotta i
got to get the uh here we go there's the
animation there's a super chat animation
[Music]
thank you andrea
she said she just got paid today got a
pocket full of change y'all
yeah thank you andrew for the super chat
boom do you guys like the new
do you like the new uh animations that
we're getting we're gonna do some some
fancy things with some animations here
we're experimenting with some things
uh for some animations do you like the
new super chat and i i'm i'm i'm fond of
it i'm fine so if you guys are listening
out there on the podcast directories
google spotify apple remember don't
forget to go subscribe to the youtube
page and catch it every once in a while
you gotta catch it on video every once
in a while and there's just some things
that the audio just
will not give you
that the video gives you
so go go check that out thank you again
andrea
for the super chat
so there's a lot of news today i want to
get to some of it before we play this
interview um with brent because that's
going to take up most of our time today
uh so i definitely want to go um to
we're not going to start the countdown
yet for the for the shitless roundup but
there is a few things
that i'd like to get to we get um let's
see what do we got today we get
we got the milky way finland ashley judd
sean hannity 49 senate democrats as you
guys seen um maybe noticed in the news
last night
they did not codify roe v wade
they did not codify roe v wade and you
know this morning trending is 49
democrats but i guess the the reason why
that should be trending
uh is because
there's only 49 democrats that voted for
this thing i guess but here's the thing
here's the thing folks
uh joe manchin said yesterday and we did
it live on the show where he said well i
will vote to codify
roe v wade but this just goes too far
it gives women's too many rats
just gives them too much of a right to
their body i just can't handle it
so joe mentioned flakes but it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter about the
democrats
listen to me when i tell you this stop
[ __ ] complaining about democrats
49 of them voted to codify roe v wade
yeah joe manchin flaked [ __ ] him
but there wasn't one not
one [ __ ] republican not
one in the senate that would vote to
codify
the rights of women's bodily autonomy
not
[ __ ]
one of them
and without that you don't get the 60.
that's the [ __ ] s that's the stick
here
and that's why joe manchin could flake
on this because it doesn't matter if joe
manchin voted for the son of a [ __ ] or
not
what we have to do folks
is use our ballots
to make sure
that what we do is form a senate that
will [ __ ] crush the filibuster kill
that son of a [ __ ] once and for all
that's what we have to do
you want to fix this
you want to make sure that women have
rights in this country get engaged stay
[ __ ] pissed
use your strategic outrage to point it
and get democrats elected
everywhere
everywhere not just in the senate
governor's races congressional races god
damn your [ __ ] dog catchers if
they're elected officials
now's the time
now
and i'll listen to these [ __ ] idiots
rather they're [ __ ] conservative
republican fascists or liberals telling
you you can't protest and you shouldn't
protest and you shouldn't ride on
sidewalks with chalk [ __ ] them [ __ ]
them now's the time to get engaged now's
the time to get active however you can
wherever you can rather it is with your
feet in the streets rather it's with the
tweets
rather it's yelling and screaming into a
microphone
donating to campaigns which is super
vitally important
we will not win we
will not win if these democratic
campaigns do not have the funds
and that we don't rely on big rich
donors folks
this isn't the gqp
this isn't the gqp where billionaires
are stuffing their stuffing gqp's
pockets to turn this into a fascist
state we don't have that situation it's
us it's we the people
and we have to make sure that these
campaigns had the funds to operate
but this morning 49 senate democrats
is trending which
it should be republicans suck is what
should be trending not 49 senate
democrats who gives a [ __ ] they voted
for it they voted
for it
we should not we should not
be blaming the people who voted to
codify roe v wade
there's 50 [ __ ] 50 of those
[ __ ]
that voted to make sure that the supreme
court definitely 100 percent will take
the rights away from women
oh but tony it was just a show vote it
was just a show vote if they would just
if they would just pare down a bill and
let them [ __ ] you they're that they
aren't gonna that is all a bunch of
[ __ ] even if you pare down a bill
just to codify just roe v wade and just
take it that far and only give only give
what is expected of the women's liberty
in this country not what is
what is [ __ ] rightfully theirs their
god-given right
as these fascists would say
they're st you're still not getting to
that level
also lisa murkowski vote for it yay
now you're at 50.
you still have not broke 60.
you still have not
we have to get enough votes in the
senate to kill the filibuster that's
what we have to do and not just kill the
son of a [ __ ] like for you know carve
it out for us we want supreme court
justices so we're gonna carve it out for
that and we want this so we're gonna no
we need to smash that [ __ ] with
a
hammer with a hammer we need to smash
that son of a [ __ ]
vitally important
so
stop blaming democrats this is not
democrats fault it is not
you may want it to be because you want
someone to blame
they bought and paid for supreme court
justices to the united states supreme
court that's what they did
bought and paid for
they don't they don't want to just take
away the right
of women's ability to make medical
decisions about their bodies
about abortion they want to take their
their their [ __ ] choice away from
them about contraception
they're trying to marry children in
tennessee and missouri they're trying to
ban math in florida
they want to make sure you can't say gay
they want to they're trying
to take away consent from parents of
their children
oh tony that's all you're hysterical
you're oh my god you're being ridiculous
am i am i being ridiculous
am i being ridiculous oh her emails her
emails
all her emails
oh he won't be that bad he'll learn how
to be presidential
he'll finally figure that out
don't worry don't worry it can't be that
bad
it won't be
it won't be that bad
i'm here to tell you it's definitely
going to be that bad
hundo percento
if we don't do something
why we don't do something is we don't
start chalking up their [ __ ]
sidewalks
i mean bury them in sidewalk chuck
that's what they're scared of apparently
they're terrified
sidewalk chuck
oh someone's gonna ride on my sidewalk
with chalk you sons of [ __ ]
thank you minus margie excited about
your live stream january 6th hearing
tony popock and kfa talked about it last
night on legal af they did i missed
legal af i was busy last night i am
definitely
margie thanks for pointing that out i am
gonna go talk or watch
uh the the legal af from last night
everyone else should too i'm gonna go
re-watch that you know what i do
here's a secret of mine that i do when i
when i want re-watch a podcast or really
any video that's not live on youtube
i go to the and maybe you should do this
with mine if you're re-watching mine
i go to the speed there's a little
there's a little settings icon down
there it's like a gear you push it and
it says playback speed and it'll set on
normal but what i do is i go to time and
a half or time in three quarters
and i watch it fast so that's one that's
one trick if you want to watch your
videos on youtube um and you don't have
a lot of time but you want to get
through the content
go to that little settings thing that's
probably what i'll do today is go watch
popoc and kfa
talk really really fast because
apparently according to midas margie
here they talked about our january 6 uh
hearing live streams that we're going to
have and that is true we are planning to
have live streams here on the tony
michaels podcast we're not sure exactly
all the ram the the
the plans here
uh but we're trying to develop those
over time because we don't know the
actual schedule yet of some of these
hearings we know they're coming in june
we're just not sure when how long and
that sort of thing so as we get closer
and closer and closer
uh we will be announcing those things
you know what when what how they're
gonna where you're gonna find them i
mean you definitely wanna subscribe to
the youtube channel because they will be
on our youtube channel
somewhere somehow some way so go
subscribe to the youtube channel
and don't forget to do that so you don't
miss those january 6 select uh committee
hearings those live streams
and we are and gonna invite guests and
of course we have to have the great
michael popock and the great kfa from
legal af on our live stream to give us
the legals the legals
uh when it comes to the january 6
election you guys know we we had kfa
karen mcnippolo when we streamed the um
marjorie taylor green hearings
um back oh geez that seems like a
century ago now actually maybe i should
ask gabe gabe do you remember when we uh
when we streamed
marjorie taylor green yeah when we when
did we stream do you remember what day
that what that seems like a century ago
doesn't it
so long ago let's let's think back let's
think back three weeks ago
okay april 30th
all right no
no no no no sorry sorry uh
april
22nd april 22nd it seems like yeah that
was a friday friday let's check the old
check the old thing here boom boom boom
yeah it was it was on a friday yeah
three weeks ago
it feels like right
when you get when you get to where
there's like six years worth of news in
a half an hour it really is because we
got a lot of news today that we're not
we're hopefully uh we're not really
going to get to and tomorrow we got bone
in the week so we're not going to be
able to pack some of this news maybe we
should go to just six hours a day gabe i
mean i'm i'm thinking that it just it's
yeah no i guess it's that much news it
really is ebola well look do i look
tired i do look tired
did you do the chalk did you do the
chalk thing
i i'm almost done with it we're okay
good i have to the audience is dying for
the uh uh
yeah i have to find one prop to to make
it work tony's read the script so he
knows kind of what happens but there's
an element that i added and i
oh from the script you sent me yeah
there's like uh there's like some action
that that that chalk cop does and i need
i need to go get something for it see
here's what happens folks is gabe
sometimes o'reina
will will write a sketch and he'll send
me the script and then i'm like you
should put this tony michael's word here
and then so if you ever if you ever see
like a gay video and there's like that
sounds like
tony sometimes he listens most of the
time he does not
he
which is probably a good idea not to
heed my advice on the screen yeah yeah
yeah but yeah it's a it's a weird ass
it's just it's a very strange the
premise the premise to begin with as
susan collins calls the cops like on the
chalk on the sidewalk is such a dumb
thing
that we really like that's the world we
live in
and then i was like you know during the
show the other day when the news broke
or it was you know i forget monday or
something uh lifetimes ago but only an
hour ago right and then i was like oh
while while we were talking i was
writing this i've rewritten that i've
rewritten that sketch a few times now
because i was like oh maybe i could do
it this way maybe i'll do that way and
then last night i came up with an
alternate like a totally different one
well i don't i don't want to give
anything away because yeah yeah
it is though it is it is as as crazy as
the situation of susan collins actually
calling the cops because sidewalk chalk
was written on her sidewalk that the the
sketch you have is just as crazy it's
not crazy or so did you see um to not to
get to some of the news here really yeah
before we get to the interview with
brent um finland
the leaders of finland have announced
their application to nato which i think
is a big [ __ ] you uh from democracy not
exactly from finland but a big [ __ ] you
from democracy uh not just to putin but
also to trumpism around the world that
hey we are going to secure western
democracy and we want to stand with it i
think that's a sweden as well is moving
to uh of course to apply to nato and and
um actually even the news farther beyond
that apparently
countries have given their backing until
finland and sweden were to actually
become part of nato so they're giving i
mean when you when you've got a country
that typically will like yeah we're kind
of we don't want to be involved we're
kind of neutral here when you get
countries like that
who they're like all right we're gonna
we're gonna enter into nato we're
actually going to back any country that
has any sort of conflict
you're
you know there's something like
if you're not with them then you're
clearly in the wrong like if someone who
is typically neutral comes in and says
hey we're gonna we're gonna join your
forces we're gonna come with you guys
uh you know that whoever's against
that group is
probably not the right person to back
you know well
again
it is a sig to me it's not like finland
wants i mean they don't want to know
but it's it's more of a signal to the
world that hey
this whole [ __ ] you're gonna come
into a country a democracy and try to
take away their sovereignty right and
kill their women and children and commit
war crimes yet you're not we're not
doing that we're not doing that that's
not what we're gonna do we're not going
back to the second world war you can
threaten nuclear war all you want but
let me tell you something if you do do
the whole nuclear war the entire world
is going to stand against you um and it
looks at least the entire world of
western democracy uh also some very sad
news uh you know naomi judd uh died um i
think that was last week right before
she received an award but it is being um
i guess ashley judd her daughter
revealed this morning that it was from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound um which is
even more disappointing probably than um
naomi judd dying it sounds like there
was a lot of depression there and
stuff like that so that's that's some
sad news so um
you know
it it
i don't i don't know why we we can't
figure this out in this country but more
firearms does not mean um less dead
people that is not a thing and i i don't
know
naomi judd's situation with firearms but
and i'm not a statistic person we don't
dump you with statistics on this podcast
we don't overwhelm you with uh those
sorts of things but there is statistics
showing that if you own a firearm you
are likely you are way more likely to
die at the hand of that firearm for
whatever reason um and it it is getting
to a situation in this country where we
really have to have not just
conversations about what governments can
do but what we can do as the people what
we can do is the people to to make sure
that we're protecting people because it
is a sad situation um when someone takes
their life especially when they take
their life
um with a firearm
you know i'm not sure exactly the
situation but
um
it's always a very very hard thing so um
very sad news about naomi judd that
ashley judd revealed this morning um
some more some more news that we have is
uh did you see that joe biden called
um trump manga king did you see this
no but i feel like every day there's
like a new
there's like a new phrase or nickname
that's given there's like ultra mega uh
republican mega mega king
this is this is the best one this is the
best one
did he release okay
did joe biden call him that before
trump made that true social post i don't
know let's let's watch let's
there's a tr wait okay now you're really
throwing me out guard there's a true
social yeah i'll find it okay find that
i i'm gonna i'm going to play this uh
joe biden clip here
that's all i need to play that's it the
great maggot king so it's a gabe that
the best part about this is maga this
morning the trump bumpers they're like
yeah we love this and they don't even
they literally
they don't even i actually i have the uh
here here i've got the
is that it is that the one that you're
that is it
that is it
so i don't know uh i have no idea i
don't know when this the return of the
great magic they don't
man they're not even catching it like
they're not even catching what he's
trying to say yep yeah yeah like i mean
like
you you gotta you gotta look at the
situation which is like
you know someone who is claim you know
he goes oh i created so many jobs well
well you brought back some jobs because
you [ __ ] just
demolished them right decimated them
because you
you
thought uh that the the uh coronavirus
would just go away right by easter it
would just miraculously go away it would
be a miracle and uh you end up finding
out that well what happens we find
ourselves in you know a bit of a
recession during that time you don't
give people money that they actually
need to reinvest in the economy and then
you just assume
that when people start hiring again
that it's that you were the one who did
it like yes you caused the problem but
you didn't offer a solution and again we
i was saying this yesterday on the show
which is like republicans have a
tendency to 100 of the time create a
problem and then not offer a solution to
that problem and this is just another
example
uh but yeah this is
the the amount of people who don't get
the joke here or the amount of people
who are doubling down and they're like
oh we're gonna you know replace biggie
smalls uh photo with trump's head or
we're gonna you know talk about how
there is a literal golden statue of
trump like
is anyone not realizing that the cult
that they're in clearly not because
they're just you know
uh recurring donations every month until
the point that they go bankrupt but
right well here's little boy lumber ben
shapiro as you as you refer to him dap
um
um he says joe biden is even worse at
branding than he is at presidenting okay
he's supposed to be smart right
this sounds like something i would i
would [ __ ] president thing is a word
that i would tweet ben shapiro you dumb
[ __ ] um stop taking my shtick
you son of a [ __ ] um here are some of
biden's attempts at branding build back
better i'm gonna agree with ben here
that is horrible branding
putin's price hike that's not bad
branding that's spot on that seems to be
the truth man and here's the thing ben
shapiro you're typing it out on your
twitter ultra maga oh that's just a lead
up to the great manga king which is him
making fun of you [ __ ] and you
don't even realize it this is the
problem with satire and parody they are
so far down that they are the actual
parody of themselves they don't even
realize when they're getting [ __ ]
made fun of now yeah they can't even see
it
the only surprise is joe biden is not
responsible for new coke i mean i don't
know is that a donald trump donald trump
junior thing new cup
it could be i don't know if it's like uh
a play on
trump loving diet coke you know or like
whatever i'm not exactly sure here ben
shapiro attempts to this is ben shapiro
right
again dude do it again dude
i'm sorry i'm sorry it should be like
this you'd be like
yeah that's it
if anyone if anyone knows the video that
i'm referring to he's like um let's go
brandon
he actually does that yeah dude here oh
god this [ __ ] video now we gotta show
the audience um the one the one tweet
that i want to show is what's her name
bridget what's her name what's this
april bridgette bridget gabriel
bridgette gabriel that's right that's
what it is this [ __ ] describe uh joe
biden in two words that what her tweet
is oh no this is i don't know
joe biden called president trump
the great manga king i love it of course
you do
of course you do you dumb son of a [ __ ]
of course you love it because
you're a [ __ ] brainwashed delusional
sycophant that's why you love when
someone would call the guy that you see
as the ultimate king as a king like
don't you [ __ ] get they're always
running around going why don't you guys
have joe biden bumper stickers why don't
you have joe biden hats why don't you
have joe biden flags why don't you have
joe biden swimming trunks yeah what's
wrong with you like because we're not
[ __ ] obsessed with him
we're not obsessed with him he's the
[ __ ] president like he's we elected
him to do a job we didn't elect him to
be our i don't know manga king
people are [ __ ] dumb
uh by the way um bridget your tweet
[ __ ] really sucks
it sucks
um so so you you can go down the manga
king thread and find this but is this
the video i sent you two videos and
you're gonna want to play them both
okay am i playing them in a certain
order play the first one i sent you and
then play the second one i sent you guys
because the
the just kind of like an
explanation of it or something nope you
really don't well yeah here just play it
and you'll see in the caption kind of
what was there
everyone everyone tuck in
put your seat belts on here get yourself
some water cause the [ __ ] room is
about to dry up you might want to get a
barf bag oh britney says gun show please
all right let's just get this oh my god
fine this is on a facebook live he's
doing this
oh britney says you know what i'm really
pissed off about with this video is no
one in our chat has ever asked us to do
a gun show
[Laughter]
now they're going to start asking
they're going to start asking for the
gabe gun show gabe gabe give him the
gabe gun show
oh yeah
no but you got to play the next one if
you play next one you'll understand it's
like he goes
let's go brandon oh so he actually says
let's go yeah yeah play tonight
i thought you were kidding no dude
you think it's all a joke but they
literally did it literally oh man you
guys wanted to laugh today
you guys want to laugh today here you go
is this is this so is this a tick tock
line it's a tick tock because somebody
responded to and i think it it's a great
delivery oh my god so he actually reads
the response
what he reads the response during it no
this is him talking about let's go
brandon again he's got the let's go
brandon this is a different this is a
different moment he is doing a live
stream different com
totally different day totally different
live stream please everyone in the chat
please please please start asking for
the gabe gun show please please let's
make this a thing let's make this a
thing where gabe
squeaks into the microphone as he tries
to flex his muscles
okay let's uh let's play let's play ben
shapiro doing his [ __ ] gun
whatever this is
let's go brandon
let's go brandon we gotta play it again
it's not very long
let's go brandon
oh my god
uh
gabe i love the intro to our show but i
almost i almost want i almost want that
now to be
the the intro to our show oh uh yeah i i
gotta say it's it is something that has
returned dividends we might have to
throw it into
just anywhere just like in the middle of
a video somewhere right well we talked
about that making that one video
so this might be something no i don't
know oh okay not that one for the show
we might have to yeah we we're working
on other channels not on youtube
facebook or right you know right it's
kind of stuff that you got to put on
you know only only fans yeah yeah okay
for sure yeah but anyway yeah that's a
ben shapiro and he has on multiple
occasions giving them the gun show and
he sounds like he's trying to be alex
jones where he's like
like he's trying to grunt he's trying to
grant and the devil is gonna go get you
like the devil's gonna come get you
let's go brandon like i feel like go
back to the news
i feel like he's more of like a uh like
a like a smeagle
uh gollum type character he goes from
schmiegel and then he's in the gum he's
like man let's go bandit you know it's
like [ __ ] creepy
it's like my precious
every everyone is uh debbie says no more
um mj's very air stomach is upset
everyone is very sorry very gross
it's very gross everything everything
has dried up in the world right there is
a global drought thanks to ben shapiro
right it seems like our entire uh our
entire chat room just went dry all of a
sudden
whoosh i can't believe that's that
i cannot believe that he actually does
that on live streams so folks
if you can uh bear the torture of going
and watching a ben shapiro live stream
and you screen cap the uh the video of
him doing his little gun shows when they
um when they do it please please send us
the videos please all out of water
even ben shapiro even dried up the the
sodastream the sodastream um supply over
at gabe's i'm all out oh my god oh my
god
that's the worst the worst thanks a lot
okay let's go back to the um
if we can go back to it before we get to
the uh the
the
interview with brent here um because
there was a couple more things that were
trending that i wanted to talk about
we're we're running short on time here
though
what was it it was manga king
what else did i have the 49 senate
democrats i kind of covered that there
was one more thing there was one oh the
sean hannity sean hannity did you see
that um i guess
he did a segment or something targeting
kathy
barnett or something i don't know what
what is this feud about you know the
craziest part gabe is i tried to prepare
the last two days i know well the thing
is i tried to go in to see what he's
training about and that whole [ __ ]
feed is just a pile of [ __ ] like it's
just like sean hannity [ __ ] all over
like in that of course it's people
[ __ ] on him as well but i mean it's
just like the whole feed is you just
can't you just can't [ __ ] stop
laughing at him or being disgusted by
him
it's just uh maybe sean hannity should
do more uh sean hannity type guns yeah
yeah yeah he would get a lot more views
maybe i wonder i wonder who at fox news
is the jester for the maggot king you
know like who who is definitely
definitely shot john hannity no no no no
no no tucker carlson tucker carlson
actually know who is the boss tucker
carlson um he he's the gesture for putin
like that he knows he's the actual he
knows he knows who the actual maggot
right right like the maggot king is
actually
putin you know
trump's just the
you know maybe like the lieutenant mega
king he's like a pl is he like a plebe
like he's like oh please sire yes you
see like uh you know still work like
indentured servitude still working that
off like in the stables right why i mean
it's kind of like uh um
in the movie robin hood the the one with
kevin costner where they were
the king is a leper right uh-huh
and his and his son bruce is is the
actual acting king
he thinks he is but he still has power
over him yeah that sort of thing lets
him think that he's he's in charge
that's him thinks he's in charge is that
too old of a reference the r robin
that's moving that's pretty that's
that's
like that's that's going with us
yeah they've also tried to remake
robinhood i feel like a few times yeah
well like which version are you talking
about i know i know i know speaking now
we make we make
uh a few old references in this
interview with brent what did you tell
me because you're you're you're friends
with with brent you guys know each other
outside the uh the screen here as it
yeah yeah um so tell me tell me what you
thought about the interview because you
edited it it's it's i i couldn't stop
laughing for the audience to know
you just hear me laugh like the entire
time yeah it's just a bunch
it's just a bunch of like us riffing
because we when we started you're like
you know so what do you want to talk
about he's like dude i'll talk about
whatever you guys want to talk about so
then we've talked for an hour yeah for
an hour like even over an hour like we
you know ended the interview and stuff
and we chat a little bit after that but
yeah it was over an hour of us just like
shooting the [ __ ] and joking we talked
about everything like we previewed a
clip yesterday about breaking down
hillbillies and white trash and rednecks
we talked about
uh
uh like in the beginning of the
interview we talk about it's a whole
fake set that he's on like right we talk
about
everything in terms of also the
characters that he does that are
incredibly hilarious we definitely
recommend that you go watch his videos
um you probably have seen him before he
sits in a truck with he's got oakley
sunglasses backwards hat and he's just
you know ranting about something that
that biden or the you know the democrats
do obviously it's all satire um
but not everyone gets it right so you
know that's that well either in the
world of manga kings it's tough to
understand it's like oh you know it is
funny and it it does get you for like
the first half but then you're also like
oh i am living in a world of people who
uh
accept this as reality you know
um
but yeah we covered so many different
things and we talked about a ton of
stuff and we've laughed a [ __ ] ton so
uh
i guess get ready to laugh you know i
hope i hope laugh you know it's like
[ __ ] uh
uh jeb bush is like clap please no but
but i think i think it's tony tony and i
laugh a ton
that's all you do is hear me in the
microphone i'm sure gabe had a tough
time editing it because that's all it
was with me it was just something it was
like jokes and then like i was trying to
go to go to all three of us
and you know the audience knows my laugh
is ridiculous absolutely ridiculous and
that's just the way it is what the hell
am i gonna do i can't change my life
robin once uh wants to remind me and
gabe don't let's not forget to watch the
turtle egg video yes i want to play this
video so after the interview we'll play
that video i wanted to bring that up so
i don't i don't forget that thank you
thank you minus robin for reminding me
because i definitely want to play that
video and talk about that on the other
side of the interview but let's do this
gabe let's do this let's go to the
interview
everyone stick around right after the
break you will see brent terry yoon me
and gabe laugh our asses off
and stick around the interview right
after this
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day recurring
and it means you'll get these trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thank you for
joining us our special guest
comedian and social media troll extrude
extraordinaire
brent theriune brent welcome to the show
thank you for joining us how are you my
friend i'm well it's good to be here i
love what you've done with the place oh
yeah it's kind of nice isn't it
yeah i like what you did with your
garage there it looks like you built a
wall and you you built the wall and uh
yeah that actually this is all green
screens
it's not it's real yeah
it's a joke sorrow set is what it really
is it just comes crashing down
the moon is behind me because i'm on the
same set that they did the moon landing
on
that would be so hilarious
if these people actually believe that
like everything behind any any quote
unquote liberal is a green screen and
george soros is sitting it's like the
man behind the curtain action
and it's all like one big one it's all
like one big warehouse
he's an old-timey director like we're
doing it on film you see
he's like 120 years old so of course
that's the kind of film you know the
film yeah yeah that he would use is like
the he's just you know what he's just
like he's recording over the jfk type
tapes he's like i got this
[Laughter]
ah that's hilarious put it in the can
like that's where it comes from
so is that is that how you started like
some of the social media videos is like
the the the pandemic or was it before
that
before
like i was doing a problem like when
people know that the character the you
know that the truck rant character um
it i started really when kaepernick
started kneeling
um and i did that one initially and then
a year later he got the contract with
nike and that one really popped so
um and then but i was doing videos
before being a dude from indianapolis
indiana nobody's really doing much for
you so the internet is the equalizer
you know let's
put stuff out there and you know
hopefully people see it right you just
[ __ ] all over the place and see if
someone will clean it up then yeah
against the wall and what sticks and
mirror it you know
yeah i mean we all three are from the
same part of the country he's from
chicago you're from india i'm from
central missouri like we can almost
throw a stone at the places that we're
from so we understand all these you know
these midwest type things right like and
and that's really part of like your
satire is this
this goofy doofus from the midwest right
not really
not really red i mean i guess it is kind
of redneck i mean i know a lot of
hillbillies right because i'm in ozarks
so i know a lot of hillbillies which is
a specific
specific type of redneck but the midwest
feel is a little different i would break
it like i would see like people tend to
lump in white trash hillbilly
i think those are three different types
of people absolutely you know like it's
you could break it down by what they
drive like uh
white trash is like a trans am type guy
but you know with like two different
color fenders of course yeah yes but
then like a you know a redneck or a
hillbilly that's more of a truck you
know but then like
hillbilly is like a lifestyle as opposed
to like redneck as an attitude if that
makes sense right yeah yeah yeah yeah
well i i know plenty of hillbillies for
sure i mean um i i at some points in my
life i is one right like
like i'm from i'm from the ozarks i grew
up at the lake of the ozarks where the
netflix series ozarks is is shot yeah so
um i i is one at to some degree so i
agree with you that hillbilly is
definitely
a lifestyle and redneck can be an
attitude because a hillbilly can be a
redneck is that what you're saying and a
redneck doesn't necessarily they're not
necessarily a hillbilly oh yeah are you
guys is this like a square can be a
rectangle but a rectangle can't be a
square
yeah absolutely 100 don't ask me to give
you more examples past the one i gave
you because
that premise might break down but okay
well you know what happens well also you
know the other thing about a square in a
rectangle you can fill in a square
rectangle or you can just do the outline
like that's kind of that's kind of the
situation when you're talking about like
white trash hillbilly redneck and we can
say all these things because
we is them right brandon yeah well you
know i asked my grandma to say wash
because it'll be wars right now like you
get that r in there so yeah that's
definitely in my uh
in my family some some redneck type
things have happened of course so well
you know you get close to st louis and
there's an r in toilet too they say
toilet yeah there's an r somewhere in
the closer you get to st louis
yeah there's an r in toilet i don't know
where it's
a real toilet yeah the toilet you go
take a [ __ ] on the tour of it
it is
bizarre like that r pops up everywhere
like it in boston you get the you know
uh
i saw it i saw it
and then but then you get a warship in
in indiana it's like that that migrates
across the country and pops up where it
shouldn't be right right well there's
ours everywhere i guess so so do you say
soda do you say soda pop do you say pop
what what do you what do what what does
your
and indy what do they say i've chosen to
be serial killer and i call it cola
i've i've chosen the route that nobody
takes oh no one calls it [ __ ] cola
but uh who calls it like rc cola like oh
man i remember having rc cola at the gym
after like we'd have our grade school
basketball games they'd be like come to
concession chan and buy some snacks and
we've also got rc cola yeah like what
the [ __ ] is he cola
it's black coca-cola
they also have fresca on tap as well oh
man
fago i i've never seen faygo on tap
either there was a pla like bloomington
illinois there used to be a comedy club
there and i would i would go to the
restaurants and every one of the
restaurants had rc cola or their
products because they were like it's
cheaper
than coke or pepsi so it was just very
bizarre like you see to even see rc cola
let alone every place around there but i
say uh soda my family will say pop so
that's i will i've chosen soda because
it's not my family i got you i got you
well you know you know my mom she she's
from like uh northern missouri
south iowa but by illinois so right
around in that area they call it pop
exclusively like you're saying
but um some folks around there would
call it so d pop so d so
yeah so d pop not soda so d pop so in my
house when i was a kid my mom because we
didn't call it pop down where i'm from
in central missouri it's called soda but
my mom would say still say saudi so in
our house it was you wanna sodi right it
wasn't a soda it was a soup
makes sense when people are like oh let
me take a road saudi right which is yeah
sure potentially taking an alcoholic
beverage but yeah road sodium is
taken on the go so i can see where sodi
comes from i don't know where it
originates from that phrase but sodi's
in that one but like i only i only call
it soda you know or or there's the oh
let me get a coke right but then coke is
universal to everything else focus yeah
what kind of coke it's not a southern
thing no it's not a southern thing
though isn't that a sudden maybe i don't
know
i think it nowadays like it's coke is
kleenex you know okay it's just that
brand name and then somebody had to tell
me i'm like clean x is the brand name
i'm like i did i thought it was just
like jacuzzi jacuzzi is the is the
actual company right that's the brand
name but now everyone calls it
ping pong
it's table tennis
yeah oh really frisbee yeah whoa whoa
wait a second wait a second
crock pot
don't nope wait wait crock pot is a
brand new stop right there
you are blowing minds right now hang on
a second are you telling me that the
game of ping pong
is not the game of ping pong that is a
brand name yeah and i'm also paid i
should full disclosure i'm paid by big
ping pong not
[Laughter]
we'll say it's available here we can we
can say whatever we want here we're on
the we're on the the interwebs so what
doesn't matter what does it mean no if
you say it enough it's real so that's
right yeah exactly what would you say
you say it three times it becomes truth
oh is that right i don't know i mean but
if i say it two more times it is okay
good five times that's candy man don't
do that
speaking of truth and untruths on the
internet so
these videos that you did
you really kind of dig into like
the the trump supporter mentality and
what i mean by that is like you're not i
mean you you are making fun of them with
satire right and you are doing it as
parody and and these folks are really
getting more and more difficult to
parody at this point but when you're
doing when you're doing those characters
um it's it's almost and i felt like your
version of that
felt so authentic so like where
is it your family members is it your
friends is the people that are around
you the people because i've i i have
family members of their trump supporters
i've lived in quote unquote trump
country my whole life like so this
trumpism thing isn't surprising to me um
you know and how it developed and where
it's at where did you get like where did
you get that character what is is it
someone you know or is it where is that
from it's just you know being living in
it i guess you know indiana's home of
mike pence uh and i live in indianapolis
but if you go a little bit out there's
it's not a city it's just
the country and people are like
certain states are all corn i'm like
i've driven across the country it's all
corn
but then you know doing shows in places
where you know it's uh you would say
it's a you're not from around here type
of town where it's like it's bob seger's
turn the page you walk in and everybody
knows that you are the guy
for the show or you're you're the guy
that doesn't live there
and you could just if you listen enough
or you you drive past enough houses and
small towns and it's the flag still it
says trump won or i saw one as one of my
favorites it's it was trump 2020 but
they crossed out the last zero and made
it a four they didn't even buy a new
home again they're expensive man the
grift is not cheap i mean yeah it's fun
it's like it's so weird how people will
just spend all this money on a dude that
doesn't care about them
and and like buy flags and all this like
but you if you drive around long enough
you see that stuff and you see i love a
bumper sticker uh just any and if i see
something that has a bunch i try to get
right up behind it to see what it what's
this person's philosophy and they're
like well that doesn't make sense with
that one and that one you know like so
you're like case studying these people
to to to develop your
your repertoire as it were is that what
you're saying like it wasn't it wasn't
intentional at first but then you fought
you know you i follow a bunch of truck
rant guys because some of them
it's just
again like you said they're not doing
parody you're they're not doing parents
no these are real it's right it's at a
certain point you're like how do you
parody clown shoes
they're already big you know like
so you watch and then and then sometimes
you're like god damn it like how was it
this far but it is you know yeah yeah
i can definitely relate to that like
aspect of
like uh okay when i because you had a
video where i was drinking urine right
in the car yeah yeah and i think katie
couric even retweeted or quote tweeting
was like what did i just
yeah i don't remember it was her name
but yeah she didn't know that it was she
didn't know it was parody
it's i think that was what i gathered
it's hard to tell when people share
stuff anymore
if they're in on it or not but i think
she was like i don't remember what she
said exactly but it was like what the
hell question mark type thing yeah
whatever well like it's so it's to kind
of touch on the point that tony brought
up is like there is a there is a an
aspect of authenticity in there and
whether it's because the sunglasses and
and the beer and you're in the car and
you know that kind of situation where
people are like okay this seems like
this is like raw this is yeah he just
like went on some rant
but people you know they like because
like any good story right you get the
hook in the first part where you're like
this guy's crazy what are you talking
about and then like
somewhere after the the halfway mark or
like the three quarters way through then
you reveal that oh this you know this is
so ridiculous this can't be real right
now obviously
every day like tony said
um
you
you get out done by reality right like
okay cool like i heightened it to here
and then tomorrow the news is like
actually that was reality and now this
is where we're at and then the next day
you're like [ __ ] okay okay let me hide
it here where it gets a point where it's
like everything's on fire all at once
and the only way to make it more extreme
is to
like it's hard to do that
and like for the for the urine example
that was one of those like well they
already are drinking urine like what's
the next step right in my the video that
i made i was like [ __ ] this is gonna
eat [ __ ] so it's a dude on the toilet
and he eats [ __ ] and some people online
were like this is insane are you kidding
me why would you do this and some people
are like oh this is hilarious
but it is very like we live in a reality
right now where it's like
is it real i don't know well you're not
if you're off you're not too far you
just wait a little bit and they might be
eating their own [ __ ] at this point
exactly it's one step further and it's
not that out of the realm of you're
already drinking urine so yeah right
well what what is the craziest thing
that you did a video about you're like
there's no this is the craziest thing
i've ever said and then months later
you're like oh my god they're actually
they're doing what i was saying is is
hilarious and funny and a joke i mean
was there something specific
i don't i would have to look back
because sometimes people will quote back
things that i said i'm like i don't
remember saying that
[Laughter]
uh yeah i would have to look back
because and it's it is weird because you
could just kind of
you know
notice trends of here's how this will go
and then eventually somebody does that
thing and you're like and then it's not
like i'm like a great predictor you
could just kind of look at things and be
like this is how it was going to end up
anyway you know right this is the
cul-de-sac that they're running down
right yeah yeah right that they're just
gonna do circles well i mean for
instance i think i think it's the wokes
giving uh rnn that we did with joe from
cheers she has a great uh satire
character called becky sue and we didn't
uh we did an uh
rnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
skit where it's um uh a carl tuckerson
um uh white privilege tonight he has a
show called white privilege tonight and
they were talking about woke's giving i
believe is what it was and then like not
but like a couple weeks later and i
forget who it was it might even been
like kaylee mcinney or something no it
was it was marjorie taylor green oh was
it she said something about wokes giving
is that what it wasn't it wasn't works
giving it was the phrase that we had
decided to use in the bit was uh
critical race training oh that's right
that and then taylor green came out just
a few weeks after was like they got this
critical race training and we're like
and like we did the parody of that thing
like weeks before yeah it just it's
crazy that that
like you said you're not predicting
anything but you do see where this the
stupidity is headed right like that's
what makes the satire and parody
sometimes
difficult and and gabe i know finds it
very difficult sometimes to find because
he'll he'll he'll text me like his
script sometimes he's like is this far
enough do you think this is
like like is it am i going one step
further enough or am i going to be
behind by the time i post this thing
yeah either too gabe where it's like is
this even is this
not even parody is just me rewriting
what they said you know yeah you're like
is this is this funny i don't know like
have i heightened it to a point where
you're like okay
this is an exaggeration and then of
course you know sometime down the line
you're like well that's news now like
that's what it's been said to why i mean
i mean for the the the queen of
destroying parody was sarah palin they
took her words
and they put it on saturday night live
and the whole country thought it was
hilarious and like that's actually what
she said like that if you watch the
interview
she literally said she could see russia
from her house right it's crazy it's
crazy stuff but you know maybe parody is
dead what do you think do you think
parody and satire is is dead or do you
think there is hope for revival of
this art form that you
so greatly do
uh no i don't think it's it's as long as
there's something to parody you cannot
there are right it will always be parody
but it again it's like i think the guys
from south park were like
again it was kind of what we just talked
about of like what whatever they write
something crazier happens
before they even get the episode out so
and that i don't i don't know when that
stops because at a certain point
something will happen and you know one
side or the other will have a take where
you're like did you even have to say
anything about this opinion like you
don't we don't like one side
automatically has to be against it and
one side has to be for it and you're
like nobody really even cared about this
thing so i don't know why
you were even talking about it you know
but it's like everybody has to have an
opinion on everything and sometimes you
don't need to have an opinion on things
you know
speaking of things that happen and have
an opinion and and not knowing where
people are going to stand because norman
like you're saying you know exactly
who's going to say what and what they're
going to say about whatever the the
incident or the news is
what i found interesting about a will
smith uh chris rock moment is like
it actually like destroyed all of that
right like i think that's why it went so
i mean other than the fact that will
smith went on stage and [ __ ] slapped
uh chris rock which is which was his
right no
oh heard it here first oh so you're
going to take that you know
alert
right right well i mean i mean
you can give us our take of that moment
we've seen uh i think it was last night
at the what is it called the hollywood
bowl is that what it's called hollywood
bowl yeah yeah it was the netflix is a
joke right festival and uh uh someone
came up on stage and and tried and i
think they kind of tackled dave
chappelle um but his security
literally turned him into a pretzel i
don't know if you've seen the video of
the pictures but the dude is
he's [ __ ] up yeah i mean uh to the
point to where
he's probably gonna have to have a lot
of surgery to fix his boneheaded move
where he thought it was a good idea to
go on stage and try to tackle dave
chappelle so i mean from going from that
moment and like the whole
everyone taking their position
and now you have this moment where dave
chappelle which has had his own
controversy now he's will smith in other
words um hey how do we put this in a box
how do you as a comedian frame this up
to make sure that you're on the right
side brent and you don't get cancelled
for the wrong
opinion because you know we have that
imaginary thing to deal with too just
don't be shitty don't be a person left
to be an [ __ ] is that what you yeah
that's pretty easy and certain people
will hate you for certain things you
said but if you think you're you know if
they're if that's a good take in a moral
position to take then who cares if
people hate you to begin with you know
uh
yeah and it's that's like again i think
it that will smith thing and the
chappelle thing is an isolated incident
i don't think that's gonna happen across
the i don't know unless you're a guy
that likes to poke the bear with your
your stand up or whatever i don't
i don't know how you guys feel about it
i just feel like
that all those now those two incidents
have blown up right but what if it was
anybody but chappelle would that have
happened i don't know so you say you
don't have people bum rushing the stage
to will smith you is that what you're
saying when you're doing your stand up
no one i don't have a lot if the that my
stand up is completely different from my
videos
i don't have a lot of hot takes oh okay
um
so you don't see you don't you don't
scorch earth the room is what you're
saying then no i'm i've never been a guy
that's like that's right i said it you
know
i said what i said and you all could go
[ __ ] yourself you should try opening
with that next time just like that just
like that's right i said it you're like
i didn't say anything what did you say i
will hold on
i want to open up with i'm going to
leave you with this
yeah i just leave yeah i think that's a
yeah that's a great i mean i would i
would stand up and be like that was some
[ __ ] multi-level [ __ ] right there
just do those two lines you can just do
those two lines and walk off and i think
they would be happy
i'm gonna leave you with this that's
right i said it
just yeah that's it that's all you need
that's all you need so so about your
stand up how long have you been doing uh
the stand-up comedy uh 17 years 17 years
you you are a veteran my friend well i
started in high school so as as a ch as
a we child but uh
yeah i just started when i was young and
uh you know
after college i was like i could get a
real job or do stand-up and so far so
good so
if you can live with your mom for a long
time that always helps
so are you are you broadcasting from
your mom's basement or have you made
enough money in stand-up that you have
bought your own basement she lives in my
attic oh
i am uh i am broadcasting from my own
house thank you oh good good well i just
you know i want to make sure of where we
where
yeah but if if anybody needs to to be
set up in my mom's place she'd be happy
to hook you up no
uh but it's like for a lot of that i was
a guy that you know if you live in the
midwest or not one of the major cities
it's like you work the road so
there was for you know pre-pandemic i
remembered i would do like 47 weeks of
staying up on the road places you know
so you didn't actually live at a house i
mean that's the thing is i if i was
paying rent on an apartment i wouldn't
have been there anyway so
right yeah you literally just placed
your laundry
so yeah yeah oh that's nice it's nice
and warm and folded so you're saying you
have like a there was a magic hamper at
your mom's house and you put your
clothes in and yeah and now that i'm
married 47 we went away
love my wife she's great just a joke
everybody just just jokes just jokes not
not being too serious we wouldn't want
to we won't want someone to think these
are our actual opinions right yeah so
growing up growing up in indiana and
becoming a stand-up comedian like how do
you how do you go from knowing that hey
i'm funny
because i i've done some uh some open
mics we discussed that before we came on
the air and and stand up is probably
one of the most difficult performances
that there is i i think because i i've
done performances and i've done the open
mic and it is it is a very difficult
performance especially for like a
smaller audience at like an open mic
night um you know the more people you
have laughing sometimes the easier it is
to get more people to laugh but
how do you go from knowing that that is
what you're going to do i think that is
a real question because there's a lot of
comics out there that move from stand up
to something else maybe they work in
film or movies or writing how did you
know like
i'm on the road 47 weeks out of the year
my mom has a magic camper that does my
laundry
and i want to do this for the rest of my
life like what is the moment that makes
that for 17 years
i remem
one of the like i guess epiphanies or
whatever i had it was like my first like
week i got to host
as a as a comic and it was like a
wednesday to sunday like a long
and i'm doing it was like the first time
doing more than like two shows in a week
and then doing more than 10 minutes
uh at a time and at the like that was my
goal was like i want to be able to host
and work a full week and then at the end
they gave me a check and i had forgotten
that i even would make money from that i
was like oh and you get money too
um so that was a thing
of like oh you can make money and this
this could be a job it depends you know
depends on
how good you are and even then
being funny is not even half of it it's
you know
know knowing who you know and all that a
lot of stuff has to happen
to fall in line for you even to to be
working anything not even a stand-up you
know um but it was like i get like that
thing in 2012 i'm like i finished school
i could get a job in radio which is what
i went for or i could get a real job
well i don't have a job now so why don't
i try stand up and so far so good you
know and it would be the car it could be
it could be the car and then you just
become the you know the persona that
you've created on online yeah i've fully
just transformed everything
every full moon i just put on oakley's
and a backwards hat
and rant at the moon so so tell us about
these videos because some of my favorite
is the jump cuts that you do sometimes
in your videos um where you're doing the
jump cuts that editing that you do
because you're not you're not just doing
a rant you're editing these videos and
you're editing the way with the jump
cuts to make them interesting to keep
people through the video um because that
is one challenge with the internet is
you gotta hold the people's attention
longer than two damn seconds so so how
do how do you like because i i've always
been interested in how gabe writes these
things because i don't write anything i
just i just start to talk and just
record it right so so how do you how do
you go like from your idea of okay this
is the subject that i want this is what
how i want to form it but this is how i
want it to look with the jump cuts quiz
because i find that always one of the
most hilarious things is the jump cuts
that you're doing because
theoretically these these trump
supporters that are doing the real
videos they're not really doing jump
cuts i mean they barely are holding the
camera correctly right yeah so how do
how do you work that into the to the
laughs that jump cut thing i mean maybe
gabe you could testify to this too but
sometimes it's just out of boredom to
let's change it up or right um or just
uh how do i not wear out my welcome you
know people like these videos but a
certain point people be like okay this
guy's doing too much with whatever so if
i can keep it fresh or for me create
creatively you know sometimes the jokes
are funny but then if i can have a funny
cut and i'm somehow laying and uh like
my seat is fully reclined like how far
can i take this medium you know like
and sometimes that's the that's more the
fun part is
if especially if it's like an evergreen
video as opposed to i gotta have a take
and i gotta have it now and it's gonna
come out right now
but sometimes it's more evergreen thing
of like
if i could say nobody wants to work
anymore while on a swing
while having a plate of nachos on my
belly like an otter
like how many ways can i say this and
have it be funny you know right and some
of that is just
boredom and some of it is let's keep it
fresh for everybody right i've always
waited for brent to show up on one of
the jump cuts in the back dash of the
car like
i was wondering can he fit in the back
dash i've been in the back seat but now
that's the back the back part is the
final frontier oh okay
i'm not trying to give anything away
i've also wanted to surf like teen wolf
uh but that's oh that's dangerous i'd
have to have more than one person doing
it no just like ghost ride the whip you
know and then jump on and then toast
yeah
look whatever the outcome of the video
whether you you know aren't injured or
you are injured i think is
beautiful you know yeah yeah but i can
definitely relate to what you're saying
is like yeah you know not wanting to
feel like
it's the same bit again and again like
oh it's the same guy he's saying about
the same things right on this different
topic let me guess he hates the thing
he's talking about you know like that
kind of thing right right and you know
and you and here's the thing like
because like the characters that we
create
like you try to find interesting ways
where it's like well maybe this guy
isn't entirely an [ __ ] like maybe
he's just like misunderstood like maybe
there are parts of that i can relate and
i can say oh you know what he's not so
bad right he he's misguided but he's not
a really bad person because everyone
you get you the the the flame of like
this guy's an [ __ ] and i don't like
him because of these things like it
it'll die out real quick
if you
uh make a few videos you're like well
that just that's just a trump supporter
or like
that's just whoever this person is is
with this really bad take on whatever it
is and it it gets really old however if
you can add different elements whether
it's like
you know they go back in the recliner or
you're on the swing set or like you're
changing the environment or whatever it
is you learn you you grow the world and
you build this environment to be like
okay yeah this guy's interesting he says
some really dumb stuff but there is
something behind this guy that's more
than just like a rant here a rant there
and i think that does a lot whether it's
a jump cut because you're like oh i need
a quick transition to get someone's
attention or something to put you in a
different scenario or it is just like
the
the the unedited we'll say cuts of you
in one situation to another situation
you're like yeah this guy doesn't have
the greatest editing ability so he would
just go from here to down here to over
there or whatever it is so it's like
there again i think it goes back to the
authenticity and you you [ __ ] libs are
just trying to humanize everything
trying to write a whole feature-length
film
backstory
but like in some of that too i love like
uh when the background is busy and that
a lot of that was my early ones were at
my mom's house
and it was i purposely wouldn't cut the
grass
for a long time and there's a privacy so
it's not like this video has been four
weeks in the making so your [ __ ]
neighbors are pissed at you for this one
video privacy fence so okay okay yeah
probably not happy but uh
or like just have a bunch of [ __ ] in the
background like that my mom's garage was
that way before i i cleaned it up but it
was like just have it be busy yeah so
like you even have to look back and be
like is that you is that a unicycle
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] is a unicycle doing in the
gym because it definitely it adds way
more to to the world where you're like
yeah like what is who who is this guy
why does he have that stuff you know or
people just you get clean your garage
comments or whatever
algorithm just to pump the algorithm
right yeah you know you got to do what
you can do speaking of the algorithm and
comments so um i don't get a lot of the
whole
trumpers coming in and hating me
obviously i'm a white dude from the
midwest it sounds like i sound like so i
think that has a lot to do with it then
i don't get a lot of the hatred there
gabe has gotten a lot of hatred
what do you do you find the trolls
amusing or do you kind of mute the
trolls because there's a lot of trolls
on the internet like this is a this is
an ongoing i guess depending on how you
look at a problem or a helpful thing
like i think the trolls are helpful like
i love my trolls i i want them to bump
the algorithm and comment and fight and
he's got a big brush is coming the troll
hair yeah absolutely absolutely so how
do you feel about the internet trolls
and and what kind of pushback do you get
for some of your stuff speaking of that
yeah i think if you're going to be a
troll at a certain point just be
entertaining
from a guy who sees a lot of comments
and stuff
just if you know oh you're fat
yes
everybody knows
if you've ever posted anything on the
internet you mo you know more than
anybody
what they're about to say to you like
it's at a certain point
oh you're fat it's like
okay
we all know
please at least create say i look like a
fat version of black well like
you know
sometimes you're like you're not even a
like a good troll there's no creativity
and that's why you are a troll because
you're sad or whatever makes you happy
to comment on all these comments or what
are all these car uh accounts or
whatever but i i think if you're gonna
be a troll at least be creative man
right some of that like you'll just see
like a sponsored facebook post and
you can tell the company chose that
person for whatever reason they've got
the weirdest eyebrows
or whatever and i just go to the
comments and i'm like let's see this
dude get roasted
let's see this person get roasted
but that's that's why the company chose
this person right for whatever feature
and i'm like
let's see how funny this is yeah you're
like i chose this woman because sex
sells i chose this dude for his eyebrows
holy crap
crazy thousands of people are gonna open
this thread and gonna read every single
comment in the thread yeah that's that
you know that's not a bad marketing
strategy if you think about it um when
you are using the the algorithms in that
way because we we had we had a troll
this morning and said i think you said
your podcast sucks and i was like thanks
for tuning in
[Laughter]
yeah you didn't even watch a video of
the internet you had to go to a place
right you're not even on main street you
walked out an alley
to tell me i said and then you came back
to give me your to give me your opinion
on the thing you went and seen and i was
like thanks for
thanks for watching i i mean that's cool
thank you that's trolling just you the
thing you do sucks okay
like
you could yeah it's like you could be
creative you it was like maybe you're
working to the height of your
intelligence but i would hope that you
would at least offer something more than
this thing sucks
or you know you're this or whatever it's
like yeah you know give me a comparison
make it interesting make me laugh like
come on don't just try to hurt my
feelings but make me cry and laugh at
the same time you're gonna do it yeah at
least let me be impressed with you you
know
yeah it's it is so that base level of oh
you you're dumb you're stupid but then
like people will hang around
for months
to tell you nothing that they haven't
already said like it's right great sure
if you want to do that it doesn't hurt
my feelings
we love our hate watchers speaking hate
watchers shout out to our hate watchers
out there we love them
as long as as long as you're not going
to say really racist or big [ __ ] in our
comments
we'll let you hang around and be it be
an [ __ ] like you said earlier like i
mean i i occasionally i occasionally get
the people who tell me to go back to my
country you know and i'm like well i was
born in chicago but all right yeah yeah
uh or people tell me to go back to my
old country buffet
see that's a good i just thought of that
right yeah right right yeah you just
started your way it changes the whole
thing right like people tell me like oh
i hope ice comes to get you and i'm like
for what
yeah like like
can we do a little bit of research here
guys like you i know you're all about
doing your own research but like [ __ ]
you could do a better job of at least
getting i've got a lot of stuff on the
internet you could do a little bit of
searching
to add a little bit of spice to it
i do love when somebody will incorrectly
attribute a stereotype to somebody else
like you didn't even try
[Laughter]
uh you know these jews are bad drivers
like like just like
you didn't even try you just
that's not even a real trope
like how did you mix this up this isn't
either yeah either scenario isn't real
but like how did you get one with the
other you know you're bad at just being
racist
right right right which is a really
horrible horrible attempt at anything if
you're just bad at being racist because
there's so many easy things that you
could that you couldn't even be and
that's yeah there's a hard thing it's
like hey that person's a racist that's
like a whole nother level it's like
you're just bad at being a racist
like you really tried and you failed and
somehow i didn't even think was possible
yeah i do love people that are like
shout out to my haters and i'm like you
don't have haters
you just
need to move out of your mom's house or
whatever i'm talking about me but uh
don't don't listen to him folks shout
out to my haters
people that love that think that the
whole world is watching
looks like we're having some technical
technical difficulties here let me see
if we can
fix this
uh give me just one second stick with me
here stick with me
video file
looks like we had something pause here
[Music]
sorry about that
we'll go to we'll go to the game here
uh with brent
so let's let's get to the game here
let's do the game
i know i leave for five minutes i am oh
my god
here it is here's the game
all right are you ready it's ready as i
can be okay okay so here's here's here's
the thing because we have a lot of good
tech here
rent so it's high tech so um when i ask
the question to answer you ring in by
giving a thumbs up so it's very high
tech um cool okay that sounds good all
right so we'll do as many questions you
guys want because these are [ __ ]
fantastic question number one and by the
way there is no winner and you're not
you're not going to win anything so i
mean besides by the way
he's going to hold it over my head in
class he's just gonna be like right i
beat gabe and trivia yeah
seed partners with loser gabe
okay so trivia question number one in
california
you can't legally buy a mouse trap
without having what
mustache
why a mustache is there a particular
reason why you picked a mustache it
seems like you know crazy law that you
okay well that is incorrect
correct that's crazy the correct answer
is a hunting license i don't i don't
know is that is that a real thing gabe
do you i have no idea this is a weird
never bought a message
a weird rule law thing i've never i well
i mean you know they're passing they're
passing laws to take away your liberty i
would imagine that maybe they'll start
passing laws to where you have to have a
hunting license to go i mean here's the
thing if they take away my guns that
means i can't i can't go and trap these
things
well you got to have an an ar-15 for
mice
yeah
you know how fast they run they're i
just got to light them up yeah they're
they're they're heavily armed okay these
these mice these these days in this
country are heavily armed you need some
some real firepower to make sure they
take anyone
tom and jerry you know how creative he
gets in that show you need a giant
magnet
yeah a huge mallet something from acme
core
okay question trivia question number two
this is another state-wide question in
texas it's illegal to swear
in front of what in front of a church
that would make sense that really would
make sense and really this thing a lot
of times probably appears in churches
during a certain ritual but the answer
here on this website which i'm sure this
website is correct it is published on
the internet so i'm sure i think this is
uber uber
so the answer is a corpse a corpse is
the answer
to question number two and i don't know
is that still is that still a thing or
is that like outdated and been repealed
why do you think even if this is real
why would you think they would make it
illegal to swear in front of a corpse
would it be like because you don't want
your dead grandma you probably because
you wanna like pay respects and swearing
but i guess it depends on what type of
family you're in like maybe swearing is
the type of respect i would give someone
right damn [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
you can do that yeah
look at this be like that
right here good ass job right right look
at the blush on that face
look at this [ __ ] casket it is nice i
don't know i don't know why you wouldn't
be able to swear in front of a course
because they can't hear you right like
it this must be a religious i don't know
are they are they really dead or they're
like going to become the undead and they
come back and like i heard you swear at
me oh i heard you swear
have you ever seen have you ever seen
the ray stevens um um
parody song waking up with the or
sitting up with the dead have you ever
seen this it's an old country oh jesus
christ you guys are from the midwest you
aren't you've never seen race stevens
setting up with the dead
i'm sorry okay gabe where are you gonna
wait is that stephen is that steven's
spell with a v or a ph
no v ray stevens i i don't know either i
don't know i'm only yeah
he doesn't matter
he doesn't own a college you elite
[ __ ] he doesn't own a college
like like like that's the thing like if
ray stevens was ray stevens but then he
went on to be like a a college professor
and and own college he would have to
change his [ __ ] name to ph instead of
yeah
is that is that what you're saying
it sounds like anyway you limp turds
okay um let's see another another um
here here we go in minnesota it is
illegal to tease
what type of animal and i
again i don't know what they mean by
teas but in minnesota it is illegal to
tease what type of animal kangaroo
minnesota are there are there a lot of
are there a lot of
yeah yeah but you guys kangaroos are
that's i would make sense right because
you like you don't want to tease a
kangaroo because the kangaroos like you
know they can't fight
yeah
you will get knocked the [ __ ] out
if you just tease it in any way you will
get rushed on stage
keep my wife's knife out your mouth mate
wait wait do do the kangaroo action
again do it again keep my voice name out
your mouth mike
perfect perfect perfect laning i wish i
wish kangaroo now was the correct answer
but the correct answer is skunks and it
makes sense that skunks is the answer
because in minnesota you know they
wouldn't want the whole pepe le pew
thing maybe because they think maybe the
skunk is kind of rapey is that why they
you know you think that's why they don't
don't tease him he'll get that way
yeah i think i think yeah it's like
don't tease him he's like that's his
kink he's into it that skunk's gonna
turn around and try to molest you so
yeah very well could go that way and
nobody benefits from a skunk going off
you know that's a that's not a me
problem that's a everybody around
problem i've never tried i've never you
know luckily knock on wood been uh
been skunked before
you wait
yeah i know there is one that lives in
the neighborhood like happy like you
are like sprayed like no just like
sprayed because there is there's one
that lives like or just hangs out near
where i live and on the right night with
a good breeze it just kind of comes in
you're like
[ __ ]
but i do i do wonder
you know like does the tomato sauce
like is that isn't it like a way to like
detox yourself from the skunk smells
like you have to bathe in tomato sauce
or something like that i think that was
on jackass it's got to be real yeah yeah
i don't know i don't know if that's an
uber fact but it might be it should be
so i'll tell you how much of a hillbilly
i am um
i actually my aunt had a pet raccoon
and i've known some people i had a pet
possum
and um it is illegal in missouri to
actually de-gland a skunk you can't take
the gland-ass gun and the reason why
they made it illegal is because a lot of
people would have pet skunks and they
would d-gland them so they wouldn't
spray people um my dad actually grew up
with a with a girl who had a pet skunk
and she would carry it everywhere in her
coat like she had the skunk in her coat
so
are they nice they're good pets then
well i mean
maybe maybe they're like a cat i have no
idea i really i mean a wild skunk if you
corner like a possum or anything you
know not to get two hillbilly on you
here but if you corner a a raccoon or a
possum or a skunk they get really
[ __ ] pissed off like they're really
[ __ ] mad that you're cornering them
and it seems like you're going to hurt
them they're like i just wanted to
rummage through this [ __ ] over here this
trash like just leaving me man right i
mean they want to scurry off and be
scared and get the hell out of there but
if you corner you know a skunk i mean
that's why they have these thing you
know like the possum has the nasty teeth
and a raccoon looks like a robber you
know and
but but the the skunk has the the the
ar-15 of the
of of the scent world right i mean they
will they will definitely mow you down
with their scent um next question here
um speaking of of taking women's liberty
away this is a good one
it was illegal for women to wear what in
19th century florence it was illegal for
women to wear what in 19th century
florence gabe
the shoes
it's just like a is this like a barefoot
in the kitchen type joke that you're
trying to make yeah like i don't i don't
know like i just think like well you
know i don't know what i mean it depends
on you know what class is a woman in
right like what is she allowed to wear
what is she not allowed to wear i don't
know i feel like men have been uh you
know deciding what women can do with
their bodies for many many years
so it's like why it's like listen if
you're in the house you don't need a
pair of shoes right
maybe that's the logic i don't know i
originally was gonna say deodorant but i
want to choose
19th century that makes sense deodorant
totally makes sense uh brent do you have
a guess on this one do you think you
know what uh in 19th century
is it pants
very close
button buttons buttons is the answer
that they have here what do they just
tie
everything
there was no zipper back then so it was
just everything had to be tied maybe
maybe gabe maybe gabe
big zipper was trying to make a trying
to make an entry into the market and
that is why
that is why with the deep state they use
the deep state to make it illegal for
women to wear buttons so that the zipper
market would take off i mean there is a
big zipper i mean i am i mean you know
you gotta have a corset or whatever
yeah
yeah it's real tight
just imagine how inconvenient everything
would be without buttons
like zippers is one thing or velcro but
if you didn't have buttons
oh
yeah no thank you i'm out it's a lot a
lot of what is it specifically about
buttons that disturbs you it's such a
basic thing we all button something
today probably
you know
yeah otherwise it'd be a drawstring i
don't know do you have a button on your
pants i i'm i'm i'm wearing i'm wearing
shorts i i i podcast now for a living i
know i don't wear i don't wear pants
that have buttons i actually i don't
have a button on my either so yeah
you're you're wearing sweatpants aren't
you i mean i'm a i i'm lucky they're
athletic pants to be honest you're
athletic paints okay oh right right i
will be sweating in them for sure
no longer can they after after the
coronavirus and the in the pandemic can
they be called sweatpants they're
athletic because you're being
aspiring to be athletic in these pants
is that the is that there's nothing
better to lounge in than athletic wear
so
what are you what are you wearing i'm
wearing activewear i'm very active right
now what are you doing i'm just laying
on the couch but i'm active yeah right
you're actively thinking about it
right right
i think i'm gonna run into the kitchen
and grab another snickers and a beer
like that's the yeah that's what you're
adding
i got a lot of things going on you know
a lot of a lot of calories being burned
right now i'm being very active i'm uh
i'm anti-button
[Laughter]
i i don't know maybe there's a supreme
court case where we can make it illegal
in this country from from women wearing
buttons i mean i i'm not i wouldn't be
surprised if that's their next their
next thing that they want to outlaw
women is to get rid of buttons and only
only active athletic wear so you guys
really suck though i will say this
buttons on jeans
is the outside of like a top button but
buttons whenever i'm like i gotta buy a
pair of jeans and they're like it
doesn't have a zipper great that's what
i want because the buttons
the amount of time you spend
buttoning your pants like your jeans
like i gotta go to the bathroom oh [ __ ]
i gotta unbutton the thing am i the
urinal or am i in the stall trying to do
this and then i'm there taking up time
trying to button it back up and and then
people like what are you doing yeah
and i'm like no i swear so then i go
into i would totally say yes yes
yeah and then i go into the stall and
someone's like oh this guy's over here
taking his [ __ ] he's like no i'm just
trying to button my pants back up yeah
it's a whole thing what do they think
you're taking a [ __ ] standing up because
you're standing up for a long time
who knows you know maybe that's in his
feet or backwards yeah
this guy's going to [ __ ] on the floor
you know you guys really suck at this
trivia thing you haven't gotten one one
of these one of these questions right
it's almost it's almost as if these
questions were unanswerable or something
and one one more one more um that i got
here
is uh what was hugh heckner's jet plane
named what was hugh hefner's jet name
named
jet plane excuse me jet plane named what
was it named steinmetz
[Music]
no brent do you have a
no
wrong answer for both of you you really
truly suck at this it would be easier it
would probably be easier if i gave you
like multiple choice and like yeah you
know that would be great you know i mean
i said my answer because that's where he
went to high school because he went to
high school a little little factoid here
for people uber oh here we go he went to
high school with my grandparents
and he was in that group of people
and so when uh
yeah so wait a second so he went to high
school with your grandma right you have
my grandma yeah and my grandpa yeah yeah
well i mean don't try to make this
muscle you're great
i'm just trying to say
d gabe do you have do you have dna is
there a dna test like the 23andme so
yeah it wasn't i mean look i mean we
we're we'll dig up you're really nervous
you're really nervous right
like listen answer the question
uh we just called him uncle heff i don't
know you know you come over and like
give us presents and be like this is
from your uncle jeff yeah i'm sure my
grandma and him would go do some stuff
for a while they said they were in the
garden i don't know
but what i will say is they they went to
high school together
and when hugh hefner was like hey look i
i need i i'm asking for a loan from
people like an investment when he was
originally starting out he came to them
and i think it was five thousand dollars
but at the time that was
a lot of money right it's a lot of
random but now yeah yeah it's a lot of
money now yeah right and back then was
for me
right
and so i think the timeline was it was
started in 1953 my grandpa served in the
korean war he came back didn't have the
money
they were you know thinking about
starting a family in a few years
and then they're like can't do it and
here i am you know so so
it's too bad gabe because the plane that
you would own or would have owned a park
i just love i googled it i googled it
can i say it and maybe let's see yes
gabe can edit it gabe can edit it in and
yeah the big bunny it is the big bunny
see ding ding ding see here that makes
sense that makes sense
here's the thing is that these questions
are now validated and all the things
that we have said now for this trivia
are absolutely 100 true and you cannot
you cannot dispute them because the
google machine right google machine said
so right brent is that is that that's
true
one's validated that means the rest of
them
i mean all
of the facts that were said in this
video must be facts because one of them
the internet says is true and the google
machine where did you find it on google
by the way did you just google it it's
on some kind of
hugh hefner jet
is it what website is it is it from the
same website that i'm looking at no i'm
just kidding
adweek.com
was the top response
uh hollywood reporter i think there's a
bunch of them and there's pictures of it
says welcome hef big bunny on there
so it's a very famously named plane and
gabe see you could have
you could have you if you if there would
have been 23 of me way back when there
may have been a time where you would
have owned a portion
i know i could be i could be i could be
doing this podcast from the jet the big
bunny
but how many times people of like hey
let me get five grand for this idea and
then people be like yeah we never saw
that guy again
[Laughter]
i mean
yeah they're like listen i just need
five grand this one time i swear i swear
i've got an idea it's gonna make it's
gonna make so much money and you're like
is this a pyramid scheme yeah what's
going on here well it's funny that you
say that because that's why i asked you
guys here uh because
five thousand dollars from both of you
does have anything to do with
pornography because if so i'm in i'm in
if it is okay yes it
does thanks thanks for playing trivia
everyone stick around after the after
the music we'll be right back thanks for
playing the trivia with us
[Music]
ah it's always okay
you guys
i look yeah thank you i so i looked this
up to figure out what because i was like
is it 40 000 and i was like that's a
[ __ ] ton of money back then
it's a thousand dollars that his mother
gave him but i think when i originally
read about it it was the equivalent
of forty thousand like in today's money
oh i see forty thousand dollars but yeah
she
she funded in part by a thousand dollar
so wait a second he was asking your
grandpa
he was he was boning your grandma in the
garden and asking grandpa for five
thousand dollars i can't wait till my
mom hears this episode
did your mom watch the show
uh maybe
i know i know i just thought hey i'll
make it relatable i'll tell you a little
bit a little factoid here
yeah well the thing is i don't know who
the other investors were but according
to what i've read online it just has
other like them his mom put in a
thousand dollars and then his other like
associates put in money so i don't know
how much they were
going for or what exactly but so his
buddies that he partied with on the
weekends in high school they put in the
other exactly yeah yeah okay well
because he needed five grand he needed
five grand brent do you have any let's
let's plug your let's plug all your
stuff get give me where to find everyone
out there tell everyone out there tell
the audience where to find
brett there hewn's um not only his
stand-up dates but all his content and
where you can follow him we want to get
you some subscribers if you don't
already have the people that we're
listening to i'm sure our fans you know
the venn diagram is you know pretty
pretty circle right it's a circle here
uh brent comedy.com for all my stuff all
the links to my social media uh if
there's a social media i'm probably on
it so you can just search my name
and um yeah are you on true social are
you on twitch i'm on now i was like
i just can't do
i'm not even gonna put the effort into
that so i just can't do it oh it's gross
over there it's a swamp and it's all
fake sure and tony gets censored any
time he posts yeah i posted something
and it was i posted a video that i cut
together of jd vance and and uh donald
trump calling him jd mandel and it got
censored immediately like before it was
even up uh it was the truth right well
you know you know that happens that
happens yeah yeah um yeah i'm on all
that stuff and brentcomedy.com and uh
i'm always posting new stand-up tour
date so i might come to your uh your
town if you live in a uh you're not from
around here town maybe or a big city so
where's your where's your next show
where's your next show i don't even know
i i know for sure i am in louisville
kentucky at a place called planet of the
tapes um it's a comedy club with a video
store in the back like a hugh hefner
type video store or just maybe is it oh
okay yeah i just need five thousand
dollars talking about i think i'm going
to start so right yeah okay okay
this isn't a thing yet it may be no you
yeah no i've seen that you you you play
there a lot that must be a favorite
place of yours to yeah one of my
favorites and i'll be in detroit
michigan uh june 30th through july 2nd
at the comedy castle that's one of my
favorite uh places to perform and
earlier than that june 11th i will be at
the funny farm in youngstown ohio so if
you're in like the cleveland area i
think that's close i don't know but uh
yeah all my dates are breakcomedy.com
fantastic fantastic awesome man i really
appreciate you joining us and and
breaking down some of your comedy i know
sometimes you know uh the content
creators and comics and comedians they
produce this they put all their hard
work a lot of people think oh you're
just grabbing your phone and just just
screwing around and sometimes it's that
way but you know you do put a lot of
thought and effort um into your videos
and into your comedy and and everyone go
if if brent is in your area go check him
out uh his stand-up it is completely
different than his than his videos i i
do have a special comment out i don't
know when it's not done and i don't know
where it will be
uh so that's
what you have you have already you'll be
on the lookout yeah it's in the can and
the special will be called what on flat
earth so everyone everyone keep uh
you're going to want to go to rent
social media because i'm sure i'm sure
eventually he'll put some sort of
announcement you know like three months
after it's aired or something
he'll put an announcement out there for
when is special and where it airs so be
looking for that on his social media
brent thank you thank you for joining us
come back any time my friend come back
on the live show where we can create
some some live you want to if you want
to come back as one of the you know as a
truck character yeah yeah by all means
gabe gabe may or may not have been uh jd
bandel on our show today so uh we got
the exclusive interview of jd mandel um
and got
jd mandel broke a lot of news today on
our show so go check that episode out
too ed brent thank you for joining us
and stick around everybody we will be
right back right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
drupists mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking with us through some
of those technical difficulties we had a
video that there
that froze there
we always always love having our guest
on thank you brent for coming on the
show we can't wait to have him back
um gabe there also is breaking news not
just that you may or may not um be
related to hugh hefner now that that
news is out there but we have
we have some breaking news about uh
looks like the documents that were
stolen from the white house from uh the
the manga king the former guy that she
king
yeah it looks like uh looks like there's
gonna be a grand jury is that correct is
it yeah it looks like a federal grand
jury has been issued to at least one
subpoena and investigators are seeing
interviews in the case of sensitive
documents that ended up at the former
president's florida home and they're
they're talking about the sensitive
documents that
look to be classified
right and property of the office of the
president united states that's what a
lot of people
you know a lot of people got confused by
this when when it was found out that he
took boxes and boxes and boxes of
documents with him yeah it seems like he
was hiding stuff i actually think at
least 15 boxes that we know of
oh is that what the report is saying
about that earlier on
that's prior news yeah i mean here it
says term he had taken to his home in
the marvel resort 15 boxes in the white
house that contained government
documents mementos gifts and letters
because
my view of it is is that he actually
didn't steal these to like hide
something he actually stole them to sell
them that's how i see it like probably
like he never he never is like oh i'm
gonna try to get away with this like he
would destroy it if he was trying to get
away with it right like that's that's
why i think his mentality goes well
so he's trying to make it he's super
strapped for cash trying to sell
anything he can you know i feel like
it's uh it's like one of those sales at
a store where like everything must go
and he like takes the boxes down and
he's like listen i've got a letter from
kim jong-un
a love letter from kim jong-un i've got
these other documents from different
people you know like who knows what else
is in them outside of the national
archives team and also the doj
i know the january 6 committee wanted to
get their hands on it
but they haven't been able to
probably because there's an active
investigation that we see right now with
a grand jury so
i'm sure more of this will develop and
we'll probably bring you more tomorrow i
have a couple videos we've got about 10
minutes left here gabe i want to go
through some videos that i want to show
you um from the news this is one that
midas robin sent me it is uh
it's
senator he's a senator steve gaines of i
think i believe is it montana or
is it is that where he's from i'm not
sure anyways he's a [ __ ] bonehead
here he is comparing um turtle eggs and
eagle eggs to human
eggs it seems that makes total sense
well it well everything they do makes
sense so let's listen in what this
bonehead has to say law
if you were to take or destroy the eggs
of a sea turtle
and i said the eggs not the hatchlings
that's also apparently the eggs
the criminal penalties are severe
i i almost it it almost feels like to me
like we were just talking on this
interview with brent like we could start
doing parodies about um omelettes here
like and it wouldn't it wouldn't take
but three weeks and they would be saying
this [ __ ] on the house
i mean it it really they honestly would
go that far
and let's listen up to a hundred
thousand dollar fine and a year in
prison now why
why do we have laws in place that
protect
the eggs of a sea turtle or the eggs of
eagles they're in [ __ ] danger you
dumb [ __ ]
how how in the [ __ ] hell do i i just
can't even we have to say these things
to these people like we have to sit them
down like look
the reason why the federal government
protects
eggs of an of an eagle and eggs of a sea
turtle
and the reason why countries protect
these animals eggs
number one is that
the eggs are not
inside their their bodies like they're
leaving them to be
to to be vulnerable to not just
predators
but also people who want to harvest them
so we make it illegal because they're
[ __ ] endangered
yeah and they're it's also it's like i
wonder why they're endangered you know
maybe for things that relate to
capitalism and expansion and you know
deforestation like there's different
things that could be tied to this but
when you compare a [ __ ]
sea turtle egg
to a baby
like
that's a good point that's a good point
because there is a and there's always a
george carlin bid it seems like there's
a george carlin bit where he actually
talks about omelets and he's talking
about chickens he's like what the hell
did chickens do chickens are good people
right like he he he makes this
exaggeration that um and and really by
steve dayne's kind of
taking george carlin's bit and trying to
do it seriously on the senate floor
right listen to what he's saying he's
admitting
gabe that eggs that are inside of a
woman
and a a clump of cells is not a human
being
he is literally saying this
on the senate floor for his argument of
why he wants to control women's bodies
he if you go back i mean we can i'm not
going to let's do it we really don't
have time but go back and listen to this
tape and really look at at it through
the lens
and you might want to go watch the
george carlin clip maybe i'll put those
two clips together and put it up on
social media for you guys to see
steve daines is actually making a really
good case here
of why a clump of cells inside of a
woman's body
is not a human yeah like he's making the
case for us here because he's such a
[ __ ] bonehead because he thinks we
truly live in the dumbest timeline
like you know and for all the for all
the like uh
foe you know pseudo christians or
whatever you want to call yourselves
like
let's let's look at like this right
there are many many passages in the
bible which talks about you know life
being formed at the first breath that
god gives right now the other part of it
too is a body is just a vessel for
for for us humans right right
now i'm sorry
to tell everyone
but it's just an empty [ __ ] vessel
when it's before like it went
when it's before it becomes a baby
before the whole time like when we we
know at what point we decide
it's just an empty vessel you're
basically taking a vas and you threw it
on the ground you broke it there's
nothing to it there weren't any flowers
in it there wasn't any actual like
substance there wasn't anything growing
in it that was actually of life
it's just a clump of cells it's just
seeds if you will and the same argument
like oh if you're killing other things
that like oh do you kill fl like
do you do you also become a criminal if
you're taking uh seeds out of the ground
right like there's
it doesn't make a lot of sense when you
make the comparison of other things you
know and i i look at this and i say
again like if you're trying to use the
christianity argument like humans are
just vessels or our bodies are just
vessels for us as a human
and we're just empty vessels until the
point at which we are actually
you know conceived we're actually the
you know when when we actually form life
right uh not just uh
and i i mean a lot of people have a lot
of different opinions on when it starts
and when it doesn't but ultimately to me
it should be up to the woman and her
doctor i mean that's way yeah it should
be up to a woman and her doctor and that
should be her liberty and her right it
doesn't
no no questions asked
speaking of the uh i want to show
another clip here this is uh
another [ __ ] bonehead that shows up
on bonehead of the week speaking of bone
of the week look out for the poll today
for tomorrow for bone of the week but
here this week really gave us a lot of
contenders [ __ ] we're gonna we're gonna
probably have a new contenders within
the next few hours to put on the pool
this is lauren bobert uh a sort of
congresswoman from colorado and i say
sort of because
this here looks like a congressional
hearing but this is a fake one this is a
fake hearing they actually are are guys
they're pretending to government is what
they're doing listen to what this
[ __ ] idiot projects listen very
carefully and know
that this is projection
unfortunately the biden regime is no
longer interested in protecting our
constitutional rights since he took
office joe biden has continued to attack
our first or second or fourth and so
many other um constitutional amendments
i find that funny the first second third
fourth and then so many others i don't
know what those first four are but you
know just so many others but listen to
what she says here at the end gabe and
this is the projection
and on multiple occasions even said that
no amendment to the constitution
is absolute so i'm just waiting for the
day that he gets rid of
a woman's right to vote
so there you go
you you
you [ __ ]
they're coming after the right to vote
because what she's saying here they're
projecting it to you people they're
showing you what they're going to say
they always do they net they never are
[ __ ]
they're never saying something about
someone else they're only saying it
about themselves it's because what
they're saying here is hey
no amendment is absolute that's what
biden says so guess what guess what
we're going to get rid of the 19th one
of course she doesn't know that the
women's right to vote is the 19th
amendment she probably doesn't know when
it was
adopted and ratified that she probably
has no [ __ ] clue the actual name of
the movement around it um but this bonet
is projecting that they're going to take
away the women's right vote that's what
i that's how i see it oh no totally i
mean i you look at it right now and it's
like oh it's just it's just abortion
it's just abortion no it's not like
we've seen this pat over the weekend and
during this week they're talking about
taking away condoms these are people who
are also running for office who are
saying you know there's the gop
candidate in arizona who said oh you
know what we should be removing condoms
from the shelves you've got marsha
blackburn who's saying contraception
should be removed only for those who are
married couples there are other
republicans who are also pushing that
same narrative and saying that the only
ability to not have children should be
those who are married and are
considering having children right like
that how messed up that is and how asked
backwards that is to say oh you got to
get married you got to do this whole
thing and then at that point you can
determine if you actually
wanna not have a kid but before that
you're gonna have to have a kid and then
we're not gonna support you and we're
not gonna give you the funding and we're
not gonna give you the support once you
have that kid so good luck with all the
life crushing debt and raising a child
on your own and having to work extra
jobs and having no sort of safety net
because republicans love to talk about
how much they hate a safety net but are
willing to take money i mean you look at
kentucky and other states
so easily they'll take money but then
[ __ ] on other people who actually need
it yep i want to show you one more
speaking of married couples you me
brought up married couples
um hakeem jeffries goes after a specific
married couple here for specific reasons
um and it has to do with this supreme
court decision and
you know
other decisions that these uh justices
and their wives may have made let's
listen in this is [ __ ] fabulous i
wish i had time to play it about three
times but here we go and if justice
thomas really wants to deal with
bullying in america or this problem of
people supposedly unwilling to accept
outcomes that they don't like i've got
some advice for justice thomas start in
your own home
have a conversation with jeannie thomas
she refused to accept the legitimacy of
the 2020 presidential election why
because she didn't like the outcome
she's also [ __ ] so instead she tried
to q a steal the election
overthrow the united states government
and install
a tyrant
that's bullying
that's being unwilling to accept
an outcome because you don't like the
results because the former twice
impeached so-called president of the
united states of america lost
legitimately to joe biden how did she
respond instead she said the bidens
should face a military tribunal in
guantanamo bay
on trumped-up charges of sedition
you've got to be kidding me
and lastly let me ask this question of
brother thomas why are you such a hater
hate on civil rights hate on women's
rights hate on reproductive rights hate
on voting rights hate on marital rights
hate on equal protection under the law
hate on liberty and justice for all hate
on free and fair elections why are you
such a hater
and you think you can get away with it
escape public scrutiny
because you think that shamelessness is
your super power mr chairman appointment
here's the news flash that's true from
the house judiciary committee of order
truth press to the ground will rise
again and truth will be your kryptonite
point uh hakeem jeffries there
absolutely scorched earth more democrats
need to do this
gabe one thing one thing that i do want
to say that um
i i almost felt at the very end of his
speech he was gonna say [ __ ] him yeah i
really i really felt the [ __ ] of it
well we could we could play the video
everyone thanks for joining us today
thanks for sticking around for a few of
the technical difficulties that we had
with the interview it's probably my
fault the video pros
remember join us tomorrow live every
single weekday monday through friday
tomorrow in the second hour we do bone
out of the week check that out on our uh
twitter page at tonymichaelspod also
you'll be able to vote on youtube so
follow us on youtube twitter twitch and
also we simulcast from the minus touch
facebook page until tomorrow morning at
noon eastern
11 central nine pacific surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking